Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to The Sexy Brutale.
Now this game caught my eye, because when you see the words
Sexy and Brutale together in one sentence, you kinda want to find out what's going on. So supposedly it's a time warping, try-
Time-Traveling murder solving something,
something, something, something. Did that make any sense? No? Good, great. This game was on sale on steam,
and I love me a good steam sale so I bought it right up
Diddly diddly
Who's going to kill me the Marquis is an enigmatic owner and creator of the sexy brutal casino mansion?
"The Marquis" is the enigmatic owner and creator of The Sexy Brutale casino mansion.
Every year he throws an extravagant rager
His impeccably trained staff cater to their every desire, but this year something is terribly, terribly wrong
The guests aren't getting what they want at all! But you can find that out for yourself,
Lafcadio Boone. (laughter)
After all you have all the time in the world, Lafcadio Boone.
It's me!
Your imminent Lafcadio Boone.
Oh, I'm dead.
Or I'm drunk. Am I drunk or dead?!
For me being drunk would be the equivalent of being dead. Because I can't drink, 'cause I'll die.
Hello?
Hi ho.
Okay.
Oh
Hi!
"Time to move, old man." Well, who you calling old, miss oily blood hair?
How do you like it, knockoff-Attack on Titan-whatchamacallit?
Alright, whatever.
Don't you saunter over to me with your blood.
(Laughter)
I don't want none of that.
Excuse you! Oh, don't even get close to- oh, what did you- why did you light my face on fire?
"Never take your mask off." Well, I kinda wanna. It was in flames.
Alright, whatever, fine. We'll give you a chance. Just a chance.
"You are not weak." Thanks for the compliment, mysterious blood-fire-face lady.
"And I will help you." Oh okay, remember I didn't ask for that?
"But he, he is so, so strong." You talking about Markiplier? Think you're talking about Markiplier there.
I mean there's a big "m" on that chair so-
Oh, my FLOOR!
Agh!
It's gonna take forev- I'm gonna need,
peroxide, you know. I got club soda for that one. "Get up." Okay.
AH! Oh good. I've got a mask-
(Laughter)
-To hide my horrible face burns! Oh boy, alright.
So the premise is,
I got to figure out how I got dead. I think. Open door. Get through the door. I'm trying!
There we go. Gotta move and then- oh ooo
Spy. Why do I wanna look there? Am I going to see something scandalous?
It must be- eh, ah, oh, hey.
Huh, "What was that?" What was what?
What are you doing?
"Calm down Reggie. They won't look for you here."
Okay, alright then.
"...probably."
What are you talking about Reggie?
Thanks for the exposition of saying your own name for me. Okay. "Go through that door."
Right!
Reggie! "Listen"?
(Shocked.)
Oh, this game is
mysterious.
Alrighty then. (Startled noise.)
Goodbye.
"Follow him through the door." what if I don't want to? I mean, I'm gonna do it anyway, but sure.
Ah.
Why?
Eh...
Okay. There's a lot of spying going on here.
Clandestine activities. What are you doing there man?
What are you doing in that vault? Hey! Are those my goodies? Are those my Goody Noodies? "Wait, where is it?"
"This is garbage!"
"Who locks garbage in a safe?" I don't know, who looks in other peoples' safes? A thief.
That's who. You want me to sick blood-fire-face lady on you?
I'll do it.
Oh.
"LUCAS! WHAT HAVE YOU DONE!" I don't know. What have I done? What have you done? "I'm terribly sorry, sir." Uh oh.
Hey! Uh oh. "No, you can't! Please!" Oh. "You don't know what's going to happen!" Uh.
"Ah. Now there I must correct you, sir."
"I know exactly what's going to happen." Okay, thank you. Inform me, because I don't-
OH!
'Kay, now I get it.
"What will happen is that I'm going to shoot you messily in the chest."
Ah.
"And then I'm gonna- then have a bastard of a-" oh.
Hey, that guy was complaining about the stain too! I didn't want that stain neither. Where am I now?
Why am I in here. Hello?
This is cool. Hey, this is cool. Hi. Who's coming?!
"He's coming!" Ah!
I- (distressed noises.)
I don't know.
Trying to... close the door. Why does it... Alright, fine then.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, are you about to shoot someone messily in the chest? "Let's have a look."
Alright number two. Nice one. You could have just pulled it off gently, but you had to break it.
"Ha! It is still loaded! Let's see if this works!" Let's see if I can- I guess there's always plan B.
If it doesn't- yeah, bash him in the face.
Oh boy, well, that's no good.
Can I spy through that? No, I can't. I can't open that one.
Doobidy. Any day now.
Okay, we're- oh, that one! I got a spy. Can I hit a sweet hard Dap from that sweet hook
"I'm terribly sor-" oh, shit
This is where the time living comes in.
"No, you can't! Please! You don't know what's going to happen!"
"Ah. Now there I must correct you, sir."
(Deep voice) "I know exactly what's going to happen." And now I do, too!
Ka-boom! Oh...
Not as dramatic the second time.
The music's nice, though. Gotta admit.
"What happens is I'm gonna shoot you messily in the chest."
"And then have a bastard of a time getting the stain out of the woodwork."
Uh, ah! My FACE!
(Laughter)
Why's my face on fire? Oh! Oh God!
I-
Oookay, that's weird! RIghty then!
Heyeyeyeyeyeyey!
Hi, blood lady. "Be calm." I'm not calm. I'm totally calm. Who are you? Who are you, Calm? My name is Calmaplier,
how are you? "You were not seen. He is not chasing you". You look back through the door
"Look back through the door."
Okay. "Where the hell is Seven Clubs?"
"He can bloody well come and help me with the body."
"I'm not lifting it on my own." Uh. Don't wanna get any blood on my mask.
"He did not see you."
Okay... "He will not chase you. No one in this mansion will. This was my gift when I touched your mask."
"It will protect you - but only for a short time. The staff are murderers here. The guests are victims."
"But they are all controlled - dominated - by the masks they wear. I've one more gift for you.
Okay. "This pocket watch is importante."
Cool.
A broken pocket watch.
Thanks for the piece of garbage, blood lady. You gonna light my face on fire again?
"I took it from the man you saw murdered. You can return it to Sixpence. He will be able to unlock its full potential."
"But first you will have to save him."
"I have to go, he will find me if I stay." Okay.
Sure, leave me- AH, MY FLOOR! Ah, my shoes!
(Angry yelling)
It'll take a nightmare to get out that stain!
"Use the pocket watch
to restart the day from 12:00 p.m. The pocket watch is partially smashed and resets at 5:00 p.m.
If you can find some way or someone to repair it you will gain more control over time."
That's a handy feature. It's not so broken now that I'm looking at it that way.
Woah.
"Here you will see the current guest or guests you are trying to save."
Okay, oh, okay, alright. Oh.
I like it.
Saturday.
I like it. Oh whoa. I'm in the Chapel apparently. Get up!
We got stuff to do! "The Marquis invites you to tonight's show-" okay, alright. Bye then
Weird okay
So what are these all about? "The chair's old but flawlessly-" (Surprised noise)
I was reading that! "As you explore The Sexy Brutale, your map will be built up with the rooms you have discovered.
Okay, alright then.
"The movement of characters you have seen will be added to the map. You can adjust the time shown on the map by using the
Time Scrubber."
Okay.
Coolie then. Oh, I got to move! Time is fast. "There's a bible on the table nearby." Okay. Good. Why...
is this then.
Several books... Clay Rockridge...
"A fire is roaring; its intensity causes your heart to race." Maybe because I remembered how my face was on fire.
Right.
Uh oh! Wait, hey, I didn't mean to come in here. Oops. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry about that.
That was my goof. Right, so if I go through this door,
and I get the gun before that other dude is able to get the gun...
Yeah, it's in the other room. Hang on. It's in the room just over here
It's in this room right here. So if I grab the gun, or maybe I unload it, I unload that gun...
Then, maybe then- "No reaction to the Pocketwatch." "Hunting rifle loading chamber is open. It may already have bullets inside."
AH!
No, I'm too late. Oh, God. It's horrible. How do I- ah-
Hey, that mask was not happy about me
Well shit. I was a little too late
"That's a much better idea. Let's do that." Wait.
But not yet. I see.
Okay, well I've got time right now to be able to unload this rifle.
Right?
Why can't I break it off of there? Oh, come on. There's got to be a way.
Crap okay, so that's already got that. So what do I do?
There's got to be a way.
"Stuffed owl, but it's still very dead." Maybe- I'm imagining that if he
Um
If I unload the rifle he'll probably just try to find another way around it.
Girl pouring wine...
All right. Hey, hey, hey
Someone was burning my face off. Who was burning my face? Hello? Oh, they can't see me. That's right.
They can't see me, so I got- heyeyey! Mask did not like me.
Ah, bullet! Ohhh!
A blank! A blanco! A blancatoid!
Where do we- okay, he's walking out of that one. Okay. My face is on fire. Oh, he took it!
Damn it, okay
I have to- how do I- f1 (key). All right, let's restart the day, because now I know what I need to do
So we gotta schwoopy doop.
I lose that, but I know where that is. So if I put the blank cartridge in the gun,
then maybe he won't be able to shoot him right away, and then, and only then
I'll have to find another way to save him because I'm pretty sure that's not how to it all goes. Okay.
Iddly dee, scaddoodily doo. (More rambling.) 'Kay, give me that sweet dank.
Oh no, that's right. He dug- ohhh.
He dug through there first, and that's- wait, was that where or was it one more over? Was it one more over?
Yeah, it was that one. Okay, so he dug through there
So I just got to wait till he dungaroos through that thing there, and then once he's done dunga wronging
There's a blank that's right over there. Ah.
Okay.
Starting to get it, starting to get it. I think I get it. Huh, so I can- I can accelerate?
There we go. Did that work?
Yeah, it must've. Right? HEY! That didn't work, that was the wrong timing! Sorry. Sorry, it didn't work.
"Ah ha!"
You know, I don't like the fact that you're robbing. So maybe, maybe it's not gracing your probate. "Ha ha! It's a bingo!"
All right, fine, man. What's a bingo?
Garbage? A blank bullet casing? "Wait, where is it?" Oh no, "This is garbage."
"Who locks garbage in a safe?"
Okay, and...
Skadanko. Okay, he's gone. Get it, get it, get it, got it, get it good. Get it- get that- okay.
Then I just got to go replace the doodader with the doodader and I'm good. I'm all kinds of set.
Now, I don't know why
I've been set upon this task,
and I'm sure am glad that my face lights on fire every time I'm near somebody. That awfully is convenient
Okay.
Over there.
"...bullet may be already inside..." But I have them!
There we go. "Blank cartridge slides in easily. The blank will be the next shot." Okay, got it. Perfect
All right, cool
Hey! (dramatic accent) "I'm terribly sorry, sir."
Kachunk. Wha- (accent) "No, you can't! Please!"
"You don't know what's going to happen!" (end accent)
Ahh.
But he does not know now what is going to happen either.
Kablam! Uh oh.
"What the hell? What... what is wrong with this blasted thing? A blank? For fff-
"There better be a second round in here." Oh.
"Otherwise it'll be Plan B for you, I'm afraid."
"Ah, that-"
Aw shit, well, well alright.
(Surprised sound)
(Happy sound)
He did it! Oh- okay. "Ha! Golden duck! Cracking job!"
Okay. Is he dead? Did you somehow belonk him into death with a candlestick?
Also, damn. That- that organ got jazzy.
Alright. "This feels very different. Why am I wearing this mask still?"
I don't know. Why are you?
Hello, welcome to the real world, sir. How you doing?
It's a peculiar thing, I think. Hmm. Very strange, indeed. "Ah, so much better!"
Alrighty then.
Hello
"Good lord, Lafcadio Boone!" (laughs) Oh ho ho, I forgot my own name!
Hello, I'm Lafcadio Boone.
"Where are we, do you know? Ah, wait, my pocket watch? I've the strangest feeling I've been looking all over for this."
"You've done quite a number on it."
Alright. Well- I don't want to give that up! That controls time!
Oh, you fixed it? Are you gonna give it- oh, thank you, okay. "There, that should see right. All fixed." Okay.
Thanks for not questioning why I have it, not you. Now, I think I should get back to the party.
Oh.
"Use the pocketwatch on any ticking clock. This will save your game and set that clock as your starting point for each  day."
"With the watch repaired the full day is now open to you."
Yay.
Hooray.
Yeahoo.
"Ah, someone's having a sly tipple on the job. Good show! Sleep it off, that man."
Oh, the dead guy, oh, the dead guy, okay, all right then.  (laughs) Reginald Sixpence is saved!
Great?
Goo- oh hi, blood lady. Aw, my floor!
Oh, you look a lot less friendly from this angle. "Take his mask." I don't know if I want to do that.
"You will need its power" Again, I don't know if 'need' is the correct word here.
I seem to have been thrust into this position by you.
All right, fine. Is this one gonna light my fire on face?
My face on fire?
My face fire?
Sure.
Oh, that feels good.
All right, clock mastery. "With Sixpence's mask, you can create a bond with clocks around the house."
(Laughs) I can speak to the emotional, like, heart of every clock
I know I can empathize with every clock in the entire house. "Use any active clock in the mansion to jump to 4:00 p.m."
"Or 8 p.m."
"You saved Reginald's life. He was the personal clockmaker to the owner of the mansion, The Marquis.
"Well, he was more than that, but..."
"But the more- the more important thing is that the clocks in the mansion are tuned to him."
"Now that you have his mask - his power - they will respond to you."
"You have to go. Quickly. Even now, the mansion is straining to undo what you've done."
"But you can fight back, saving one life at a time."
"This day will start again. I pray that Sixpence's power will free you from these rooms."
"If you are lost, find me in the Casino. I will look for you by the clock." Again, okay,
I get it, by the clock. "There's so many more guests here who need your help."
Okay. Why can't YOU help them, blood lady?
Nevermind then. Just gonna go back in time. Don't mind me.
Cool.
Great. Saturday.
Again. Got that Saturday Night Fever.
Boogie Woogie woogie-ing all night long.
Oh.
Hi, I thought I clobbered you
Or is that different? Are you Two of Diamonds?
Okay...
That's it
Maybe that IS you. "You know, it's days like this I wish I were LESS competent. Then maybe I wouldn't get the tricky jobs."
Oh, hey! Welcome to The Sexy Brutale!
Okay, alright then. Anyway. I can save. Eh, cool
Well anyway, that is The Sexy Brutale. I don't know if I'm gonna play a full round of this one,
it seems like it's gonna be a bit of a longer game, but it's an interesting concept. I like it a lot.
I might do a couple more episodes, just because I'm curious as to what's gonna happen next. But either way,
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down in the comments below. And as always, I will see YOU
In the next video! Buh-bye!
(Outro music)